um
how did you getting shot change your
life um
realize this [ __ ] is real because that's
the [ __ ] could be over like yeah man
cause you know i've been i i've never
been shot but i got into a really bad
accident and uh
it was very like just to know like oh
yeah because it's not so much that
getting shot it's just facing mortality
like period right just knowing you can
be up out of here just it just changes
the way that you look at life because
you go to sleep thinking tomorrow's
promise
you always think that yeah yeah we grow
up a certain way where it's like yeah
we're so like you know what i mean i
think we grew up in an era
uh where it's like you know we got good
medicine we ain't had to deal with polio
yeah you know what i'm saying but for
the most part it's like
you know this [ __ ] could really be over
and there's nothing you could do about
it
did it make you like move any
differently did it make you to change
anything that you did as far as just
like
i mean yeah naturally but i always say
like
for me like getting shot i was in the
wrong place at the wrong time so
i probably would feel about it different
if it was somebody actually looking for
jason or somebody like trump they
weren't like the cash
seeking you out yeah like if it was that
didn't it you know what i mean i
probably
move even way more different but it's
just like that's just some l.a [ __ ] like
that like you might just get caught like
in in in
in a bad place at a bad time wrong place
wrong time and it could just be up like
that
but nah um you definitely definitely
become a lot more
cautious mindful of you know what i mean
like
where you at or who knows where you're
at
um just how you move yeah especially now
you know
you get the new baby and you know things
that you got a lot more to live for man
right and then you know everybody ain't
happy for you
most people aren't happy for you that
are from where you're from
like i feel like you know most of the
people who hate my guts
are because like they didn't make it out
of where i'm from like you know what i'm
saying like my biggest haters in the
world are in my hometown
yeah of course i feel like you know
obviously you're gonna have people happy
for you but like
your biggest haters usually are from
your hometown yeah i get a lot of love
at home
i mean that's important but i just mean
like in general like you know like
there's probably like five or six people
who are so envious
of your success the scary part about
that is the people that feel that way
like
you'll never know it you'll never know
it you might see them and they hug you
and they tell you how much they [ __ ]
with you so you you would never know
so i always you know like i don't i
ain't funny stuff so i
you know it's i'm cool right but i kind
of try to stick to just
you know my comfort
because i don't even want to put myself
in the position where i have to find out
how somebody really feel about me that's
some real [ __ ] man